la verdad es que me adelanté un poco en
este vídeo y ya escribía aquí la
expresión para el producto cruz de dos
vectores porque a continuación en este
vídeo que haber una fórmula padrísima
para el producto cruz y es que esta
expresión a la que quiero llegar es muy
parecida a esta otra expresión que
habíamos sacado con el producto punto a
la longitud de a que va a multiplicar a
la longitud de b que va a multiplicar a
su vez al coseno del ángulo formado
entre estos dos vectores recuerdas y es
que cuando empezamos a ver el ángulo
entre dos vectores llegamos a esta
igualdad que tenemos aquí y curiosamente
en este vídeo lo que quiero llegar es a
demostrar esta expresión que voy a poner
aquí voy a decir que la longitud de la
cruz b es decir sacamos el producto cruz
entre los vectores ya esto le sacamos la
longitud no olvides que el producto cruz
nos da de resultado un vector es igual a
la longitud del vector a que va a
multiplicar a su vez también a la
longitud del vector b y que va a
multiplicar todo a su vez al seno del
ángulo formado entre estos dos vectores
y te das cuenta que estas dos fórmulas
son casi muy parecidas
nosotros podemos asociar el producto
punto algo xenón el producto cruz al
seno y ya acabamos está padrísimo porque
las dos tienen que ver con la longitud
de a que multiplica la longitud de 20
das cuenta y es que yo sé que también lo
puedes decir oye sal es que esta
igualdad que tenemos aquí la puedo
obtener de cualquier libro de texto de
álgebra lineal sin embargo en esta
ocasión lo que quiero es probar esta
igualdad que tenemos aquí y si no
quieres probar esta igualdad y solamente
le quieres dar como dogma de fe
puedes hacerlo sin embargo aunque la
demostración es un poco constructiva y
no va a ser una demostración fácil es la
demostración que vale mucho la pena ver
y aprenderla para que veas cómo se
demuestra este tipo de igualdades que
tenemos aquí a bien tú puedes pasar sin
verla pero también creo que sería muy
bueno que no dejarás de ver este vídeo y
vieras la demostración de esta igualdad
que tenemos aquí así que vamos a empezar
me voy a tomar la longitud de la cruz ve
y ya está la voy a elevar al cuadrado y
bueno esto recuerda que es lo mismo que
la cruz de punto a cruz ve pero esto
sería muy
algo de escribir así que lo que voy a
hacer es tomarme la definición de
longitud recuerdas la longitud de x
elevada al cuadrado era igual le
quitábamos la raíz cuadrada y solamente
me quedaban las componentes elevadas al
cuadrado me quedaría
x una elevada al cuadrado más x 2
elevado al cuadrado más así hasta x en
elevado al cuadrado si x estuviera en rn
aquí como tenemos un vector de tres
dimensiones lo que tenemos que hacer es
elevar cada una de las componentes de
este vector de tres dimensiones al
cuadrado es decir esto de aquí elevarlo
al cuadrado déjeme escribirlo aquí a 2 x
b 3 menos a 3 x b 2 esto lo tengo que
elevar al cuadrado y después a esto le
tengo que agregar la siguiente
componente elevado al cuadrado es decir
a 3 x b 1 menos a 1 x b 3 esto elevado
al cuadrado y después tendría que hacer
lo mismo con la tercer componente es
decir a 1 b 2 menos a 2 x b 1 todo esto
elevado al cuadrado y si te das cuenta
estos son binomios al cuadrado perfectos
por lo tanto puedo yo resuelve para cada
una
expresiones coloridas que yo tengo aquí
así que a ver vamos a ver primero con
color rosa qué es lo que me quedaría
tengo a 23 elevado al cuadrado pues es
humedad a 2 elevado al cuadrado b 3
elevado al cuadrado déjenme escribirlo a
2 elevado al cuadrado b 3 elevado al
cuadrado y después decimos menos dos
veces el primero por el segundo entonces
me va a quedar menos dos veces a 2 a 3 b
2 b 3 ya lo estoy acomodando para que
sea mucho más fácil verlo todo con as y
con ves todo ordenadito y al final me
quedaría el último término elevado al
cuadrado es decir a 3 al cuadrado b 2 al
cuadrado bueno esto es elevar el primer
binomio al cuadrado perfecto ahora si
nos fijamos en el segundo binomio al
cuadrado perfecto que me va a quedar a 3
elevado al cuadrado de 1 elevado al
cuadrado menos dos veces el primero por
el segundo es decir a uno a tres por b 1
b 3 más el cuadrado del segundo que es a
1 elevado al cuadrado de 3 elevado al
cuadrado perfecto ahora que hace lo
mismo con la expresión de azul y me va a
quedar más
a uno elevado al cuadrado de dos elevado
al cuadrado menos dos veces el primero
por el segundo es decir menos dos veces
a uno a dos b1 b2 y después hay que
elevar el segundo término al cuadrado y
me va a quedar a dos elevado al cuadrado
veo uno elevado al cuadrado perfecto ya
tengo todo esto que tengo aquí ya debe
cada uno de estos términos al cuadrado y
a continuación lo que voy a hacer es
actualizar las as ya sea la 2 a 1 a 3
levas al cuadrado para que me quede esto
mucho mejor de tratar en un futuro así
que vamos a factorizar lo más que
podamos así que primero fijémonos en uno
elevado al cuadrado que a su vez
multiplica a quien me queda a 1 elevado
al cuadrado que subes multiplica a b 2
elevado al cuadrado ya b 3 elevado al
cuadrado es decir a un elevado al
cuadrado que multiplica menos elevado al
cuadrado más de 3 elevado al cuadrado
perfecto vamos a hacer lo mismo con a 2
elevado al cuadrado
esto es aquí me queda esta y esto de
aquí y me queda a 2 elevada al cuadrado
que multiplica a su vez a b1
al cuadrado más de 3 elevado al cuadrado
y bueno pues voy a hacer lo mismo para
atrás me va a quedar a 3 elevado al
cuadrado donde están aquí lo voy a
escribir más a 3 elevado al cuadrado
otra vez con color amarillo y es esta y
este de aquí que multiplica a b1 elevado
al cuadrado más b 2 elevado al cuadrado
muy bien y después de estos términos que
tengo aquí en medio voy a factorizar el
menos 2 si te das cuenta el menos 2 es
un factor común por lo tanto para
hacerlo mucho más sencillo voy a
factorizar este menos 2 y me va a quedar
menos 2 que multiplica y deja escrito es
que está aquí menos 2 que multiplica a 2
por tres dedos por b tres más a uno por
a tres por b uno por de tres más
a uno por dos por ver uno por de dos a
uno por a dos por uno por b 2 muy bien
ya tengo esta expresión que tengo aquí
ahora déjenme dejarla aquí por un ratito
no voy a trabajar mucho más en ella y lo
que quiero hacer es tomarme otra
igualdad para que vayamos poco
atando cabos y lo que quiero es que esto
no lo toquemos por ahorita y me voy a
fijar en la siguiente expresión voy a
fijar otra vez en la cruz b elevado al
cuadrado
ahora que otra cosa podemos tomar que ya
sabemos me voy a tomar que a punto b es
igual a la longitud de a que multiplica
la longitud de b por el coseno del
ángulo teta lo voy a escribir aquí esto
ya lo habíamos visto la longitud de a
por la longitud de b por el coseno del
ángulo teta es lo mismo que a punto b y
bueno a punto b lo podemos calcular a
punto b keynes es a 1 v1 más a 2 b 2 más
a 3 b 3 esto ya lo sabíamos perfecto a
continuación lo que quiero que veamos es
lo siguiente qué pasa si para hacerse
problema un poco más divertido me voy a
tomar los cuadrados de todo esta
expresión que tengo aquí abajo es decir
voy a llevar toda esta expresión al
cuadrado y me va a quedar la longitud de
la elevada al cuadrado la longitud de b
elevado al cuadrado y el coseno cuadrado
del ángulo y aquí me va a quedar este
cuadrado y de aquí de este lado me va a
quedar
bien este otro cuadrado que por cierto
pues vamos a resolverlo a todo esto de
aquí pues lo voy a multiplicar por sí
mismo es decir a un 91 más a 2 b2 b3 b3
y lo único que estoy haciendo es tomarme
la definición de un cuadrado y ahora sí
vamos a multiplicar este de aquí por
todo esto de acá y que me va a quedar
pues si te das cuenta lo único que hay
que hacer es multiplicar término término
todos los de aquí por todos los de acá a
un 91 por a un 91 pues es a 1 al
cuadrado de 1 al cuadrado a 1 al
cuadrado de 1 al cuadrado perfecto ahora
me va a quedar a 1 b 1 que multiplica a
2 b 2 pues esto es a 1 b 1 a 2 b 2
o dicho de otra manera a1 a2 b1 b2 b1 b2
y después hay que multiplicar a esto de
aquí por el último me va a quedar
pues a 1 a 3 b1 b3 b1 b3 perfecto y
ahora lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar
el siguiente término que es este de aquí
y me queda a 2 b 2 que multiplica a 1 v1
pero esto ya lo teníamos escrito aquí
abajo esto es lo mismo que esto
entonces me va a quedar a1 a2 b1 b2 o
mejor así para que lo veas más claro a1
a2 b1 b2 perfecto porque esto de usted
no se van a sumar tarde o temprano y
bueno después me queda a dos dedos que
multiplica a 2 b 2 pues esto es a 2 b 2
elevado al cuadrado a 2 elevado al
cuadrado de 2 elevado al cuadrado y
después sigue a 2 b2 que multiplica a 3
b 3 aquí no tenemos nada así entonces lo
voy a poner hasta acá me va a quedar a 2
a 3 b2 b3 a 2 a 3 b 2 b 3 perfecto ahora
vámonos con el siguiente que es a 3 b 3
que va a multiplicar a su vez a todos
los que están allá entonces me queda
vamos a cambiar de color para no
confundirnos a 3 b 3 que va a
multiplicar a 1 v1 déjame ponerlo aquí
esto que va a multiplicar a todos los de
acá y el principio de piedad a 1 a 3 b1
b3 que es justo desde que tenemos aquí
entonces que me escribió aquí abajo
porque le vamos a sumar tarde o temprano
a 3 b 3
uno de uno a uno ve uno perfecto y
después me queda a tres b tres que
multiplica a dos dedos y es justo este
que tenemos aquí también a 3 b 3 a 2 b 2
entonces los voy a poner aquí abajo
porque los voy a sumar tarde o temprano
y por último me queda a 3 b 3 que
multiplica a 3 b 3 lo cual me da a 3
elevado al cuadrado que multiplica a b3
elevado al cuadrado
y bueno si simplificó todo esto que me
va a quedar pues esto es lo mismo que
aún no elevado al cuadrado de 1 elevado
al cuadrado más a 2 elevado al cuadrado
por b 2 elevado al cuadrado más a 3
elevado al cuadrado por b 3 elevado al
cuadrado
así déjame escribirlo aquí a uno elevado
al cuadrado por de uno elevado al
cuadrado después vamos con los dos a dos
elevado al cuadrado por de 2 elevado al
cuadrado más ahora vamos con los 3 a 3
elevado al cuadrado por b 3 elevado al
cuadrado a 3 al cuadrado de 3 al
cuadrado muy bien y ahora vamos a
fijarnos en todo lo que nos queda y
después aquí tengo 2
a veces fíjate bien tengo dos veces este
y también tengo otras dos veces este y
por último también tengo otras dos veces
este entonces que me queda y de una vez
voy a factorizar el 2 y me va a quedar
dos veces a1 a2 b1 b2 a1 a2 b1 b2 más a
1 a 3 b1 b3 más a 1 a 3 b1 b3 más a 2 a
3 b 2 b 3 a 2 a 3 d 2 b 3 perfecto b2 b3
y entonces a continuación lo que voy a
hacer es fíjate bien hemos construido
tantos cuadrados que lo que yo quiero
hacer es tomarme todo esto que tengo
aquí de verde e intentar eliminarlo con
justo esto que tengo aquí de azul es
decir fíjate que esto y esto es lo mismo
te das cuenta tenemos los mismos
términos aquí a1 a2 b1 b2 después tengo
a 1 a 3 b 1 b 3 es este de aquí y por
último tengo a 2 a 3 b2 b3
2 a 3 d 2 b 3 aquí aquí está aquí algo
raro con los temas de tacharlo porque es
multiplicación a 2 a 3 b 2 b 3 a 2 a 3 d
2 b 3 y estos dos también están aquí y
si te das cuenta a tiene un +2 todo esto
de aquí arriba hay un -2 todo esto
estaría genial que los pudiéramos
cancelar y como los podemos cancelar
pues ya tenemos todo al cuadrado pues
qué te parece si a continuación me tomo
pues la suma de estas dos expresiones
que acabamos de construir es decir me
voy a tomar la suma de la longitud de la
cruz bem elevado al cuadrado déjenme
notar lo que a cruz ven ya esto lo voy a
calcular su longitud elevada al cuadrado
esto ya lo tenemos aquí arriba ya esto
le voy a sumar es va a ser un 9 mil
sumandos y me otros sumando va a ser la
longitud de up elevada al cuadrado por
la longitud de b elevada al cuadrado por
el coseno cuadrado del ángulo del ángulo
que se forma entre esos dos vectores y
bueno si te das cuenta al sumar este y
éste se va a cancelar todo esto que
tengo aquí yo
-2 todo esto y aquí abajo tengo más 2
todo esto y como son términos iguales se
cancelan así que déjenme ponerlo aquí
este término que tengo aquí todo esto
que está aquí como es negativo y aquí es
positivo se van a cancelar lo voy a
poner aquí se cancelan estos dos se van
a cancelar perfecto y entonces después
me va a quedar a 1 elevado al cuadrado
que es te das cuenta lo tengo aquí y
puedo hacer una actualización más me
quedaría a 1 elevado al cuadrado que va
a multiplicar y pues ahora va a
multiplicar tanto a b1 elevado al
cuadrado como abetos elevado al cuadrado
como a b3 leb al cuadrado por lo tanto
lo puedo poner decir a 1 elevado al
cuadrado que multiplica primero a b1
elevado al cuadrado y después también va
a multiplicar a veces elevado al
cuadrado y también a b3 elevado al
cuadrado de un elevado al cuadrado más b
2 al cuadrado más de 3 elevado al
cuadrado y vamos a fijarnos en a 2
elevado al cuadrado y si te das cuenta
que tengo a b1 eleva al cuadrado aquí
abajo tengo a b 2 elevado al cuadrado y
aquí arriba también tengo a b3 elevado
al cuadrado por lo tanto me queda a 2
elevado al cuadrado que multiplica
elevado al cuadrado más b 2 elevado al
cuadrado más b tres elevado al cuadrado
y que va a pasar por una 3 voy a ponerlo
aquí a 3 elevado al cuadrado a quien va
a multiplicar va a multiplicar pues sabe
1 elevado al cuadrado más b 2 elevado al
cuadrado y abajo también tengo a b3
elevado al cuadrado por lo tanto más b 3
elevado al cuadrado y si te das cuenta
en estos tres tenemos como un factor
común
avn una elevado al cuadrado más b 2
elevado al cuadrado más b 3 elevado al
cuadrado por lo tanto vamos a sacarlo
como un factor común y me va a quedar
por agrupación de uno elevado al
cuadrado más b 2 elevado al cuadrado más
b 3 elevado al cuadrado que va a
multiplicar a su vez pues fíjate primero
multiplica a un elevado al cuadrado
después multiplica a todos elevado al
cuadrado y para finalizar multiplica a 3
elevado al cuadrado por lo tanto me
quedaré uno elevado al cuadrado más b 2
elevado al cuadrado más b 3 0 al
cuadrado que a su vez multiplica a 1
elevado al cuadrado más a 2 elevado al
cuadrado más a 3 elevado al cuadrado
pero quién es esto de verde que tengo
aquí si te das cuenta es son los
componentes elevadas al cuadrado y suma
es decir la longitud debe elevado al
cuadrado y de igual manera para esto
rosa que tengo aquí a uno elevado al
cuadrado más a dos elevado al cuadrado
más a tres elevado al cuadrado es lo
mismo que la longitud de a elevado al
cuadrado eso ya lo sabíamos entonces
déjeme poner el lado izquierdo la
longitud de la cruz b elevada al
cuadrado más la longitud de a elevada al
cuadrado por la longitud del ba al
cuadrado por el coche no cuadrado del
ángulo que se forma es más déjame tratar
de copiarlo y pegarlo del mismo color
amarillo que tengo aquí arriba déjame
copiar y pegar va a ser más rápido
control se control de qué pasa ahora qué
pasa aunque hay mejor lo pongo así más
rápido la longitud de a elevado al
cuadrado más de longitud cp elevado al
cuadrado que a su vez multiplica al
coseno cuadrado del ángulo que es forman
es igual a esto que tenemos aquí y si te
das cuenta se simplificó bastante del
otro lado del lado derecho solamente
tenemos las dos longitudes elevadas al
cuadrado entonces déjame despejar la
longitud de la cruz b elevada al
cuadrado eso que va a ser igual pues
bueno del otro lado voy a pasar
estando a todo esto que tengo aquí de
amarillo es decir del otro lado me va a
quedar esto que ya tengo del lado
derecho ya esto lo tengo que quitar lo
que tengo de amarillo es decir a esto el
tengo que quitar menos la longitud de a
elevado al cuadrado menos la longitud de
b elevada al cuadrado por el coseno
cuadrado del ángulo que se forma entre
los dos y si te das cuenta aquí tengo
como factor común a la longitud de a
elevada al cuadrado por la longitud de b
elevada al cuadrado vamos a ponerlo aquí
la longitud de a elevar al cuadrado por
la longitud de b elevado al cuadrado que
multiplica quién bueno en primer lugar
multiplica aquí tenemos a un 11 que
multiplica todo esto entonces me queda
uno menos el coseno cuadrado del ángulo
que se forma y si te das cuenta lo único
que hemos hecho es despejar la longitud
de la cruz b elevado al cuadrado y bueno
ya casi está porque si nosotros nos
acordamos de la identidad
trigonométricas más importante que
existe que dice que el seno cuadrado de
un ángulo más el coste no cuadrado de un
ángulo es igual a 1 entonces ya podemos
despejar al seno cuadrado de este ángulo
el seno cuadrado de este ángulo es igual
a 1 menos el coste no cuadrado de ésta
por lo tanto está hecho esto de aquí y
me queda solamente el seno cuadrado del
ángulo y es justo a lo que queríamos
llegar déjame escribirlo aquí con color
blanco de que ya llegamos a la respuesta
y ahora sí voy a cancelar los cuadrados
es exactamente lo mismo que la longitud
de a por la longitud de b por el seno
del ángulo fíjate que cancele de los dos
lados todos los cuadrados y llegamos
justo a lo que queríamos probar por fin
obtuvimos la demostración de esta
fórmula o de esta igualdad que teníamos
en un principio y así ya sabes por fin
cada vez que veas un libro de texto de
dónde sale esta igualdad y debes de
sentir gran satisfacción y está genial
porque entonces ya puedo parar este
vídeo antes de que encuentre algún error
y además con una sonrisa en los labios